we're losing so many of our natural
reefs so we need to start to think
creatively about what are the resources
that we already have that could
contribute to the environment our
mission at Blue latitudes is to find
areas of our oceans that deserve to be
protected but maybe they don't get the
recognition that a lot of coral reefs do
coral reefs protect the resources that
we have on land and we don't even really
realize how important our oceans are
[Music]
we work repurposing offshore oil and gas
platforms as artificial reefs coral
reefs they've been around for millennia
but they're also very sensitive
even one degree of temperature
difference within the ocean can cause
them to start to bleach and eventually
die off and when the coral goes the fish
go and other species that are associated
with it if you think about a forest if
you started losing all of our trees and
all the species associated with that
need to start to think to yourself
what's going on here you know the coral
reefs really serve as the canary in the
coalmine for our oceans
California's offshore oil and gas
platforms are some of the most
productive ecosystems on this planet you
know an oil platform is not necessarily
what you associate with a coral reef but
if it's working and it's special there
could be a way to preserve it and allow
it to continue to thrive the rig service
program promotes instead of completely
removing the oil platform jacket leaving
it in place to continue to serve as an
artificial reef every year we do a few
dives off the platform's here in
California and we try to capture the
beauty of these platforms with big
schools of fish the sea lions that come
in and out because that really
communicates the story and that really
helps to illustrate what we're talking
about when we say oil platforms as reefs
we have great conditions it looks like
it's a beautiful day gosh it's so
beautiful
yep what if these structures were to be
reef this area that we see up from the
surface would be gone what would be left
is what we're about to dime on and when
we're about to see below the surface
[Music]
every beam in crossbeam is covered in
life we see scallops and enemies mussels
schools of fish
[Music]
there's a lot of science that's been
going on that they're studying these
reefs they're measuring the productivity
of these reefs and they're starting to
really understand how important they are
to the ecosystem because we do know that
they're producing life I think what
inspires me is we truly believe in this
program and when you have a belief in
something you chase it down anytime we
dive on any of the platforms we think
about what a shame it would be to lose
it
[Music]
we know what these wreaths look like
we've douve on them we've researched
them we understand the value of these of
these massive thriving rates through
motivated to find a way to work with oil
companies and legislators to preserve
these structures rich serif' sets save
the oil platforms it's not save the
whales so inherently it's it's a
challenge but I think people are very
willing to think outside the box and
when they see the videos and when they
see the photos they start to believe we
do feel like we're making a difference
and that's very fulfilling to have a
purpose like that if you can wake up
every day and feel good about what
you're doing and enjoy what you're doing
and do it with your best friend then
it's really a win-win situation
the whole world is watching what
California does so if we can work with
California to send an example that
reefing is something that should be
considered we want to set that standard
at an international level so that's the
big big picture goal
[Music]
you
[Music]